co-founder and CEO of water life India
what we do is a wide safe and clean
water to the underserved people in rural
areas and also in urban slums in a
sustainable manner what we do is we find
out the need of safe water in areas in
rural areas which are contaminated with
water or have contaminated water and
hence resulting in death diseases and
and so many attempt and thrusts and
infant mortalities and we try to provide
these safe water systems and also
provide operation and maintenance for
mountain periods to make them
sustainable the fact is that water is a
global problem and even in India we are
ranked as 122 out of 123 countries in
the safety water index 4,000 children
die every day because of water-borne
diseases we have two thirds of hospital
beds which are filled with water
patients with waterborne diseases and
6,400 are more crows or cookies spent on
medical expenses and millions and
millions of children who grow stunted
because of lack of supporters so that's
what we are trying to address in a very
sustainable manner we not only provide
the community water purification systems
but also building operation and
maintenance for long-term clinics &
poor's that we charge the consumers a
very small user piece of 325 rupees for
20 litres of water and we do service we
hire people from the village off in the
local area we train them they operated
we hire service people and quality
people so that they can operate and
maintain maintain the plan so these are
two forms of sustainability rated
economic and social their why we provide
education and awareness and involved
with the community
away from contaminated water to safe
water and health and the third aspect is
environmental sustainability where we
try to Kauai clean green and
environmentally friendly technologies to
solve this that has been our mission and
you want to provide safe water to
everyone by 2020 that's our goal and we
are making very good progress rules
thank